A friend recently told me a secret
I hate to have a secret
Knowing a secret is like opening a door to another universe.
The beast inside the gate will destroy your life.
You play too much (hands)
I am not a good show, my job is to share my life on the Internet.
Experience, and a variety of ideas
So I am not a good emotional trash can, I can’t fix your moral problems.
Maybe I can't help but make a promotion on my video.
So I feel like holding a bomb every minute.
Hey Anna, how are you doing?
Prefer not to say
what happened to you?
To shut up! Don't bother me when you walk away!
I go! Ok, sorry.
Wait! I am sorry!
Ok, don't tell others
No! ANNA!
I have to hide it!
What happened?
Isn't it only me who I think so?
Knowing a secret will make me stressful.
Let you be physically and mentally tired, always with you
eat
jobs
To the restroom
At all times, I want to reveal the secrets of my heart.
I will be a bad president.
Madam President, you can’t tell our nation’s top secrets.
If the president thinks this is not a secret, then this is not a secret.
You are right, Madame, but as your adviser, I still advise you not to leak it.
But everyone has the right to know the existence of aliens
Otherwise we will lose the chance to be friends with aliens.
This will spread the panic
I am very scared now!
You simply don't understand the pain of not being able to share the secret of killing JFK.
If my secret booklet can't be shared with anyone, it's better to kill me.
I know the secret of Area 51.
Secret to the moon
Obama's favorite food!
Pizza, day! Obama can really rely on
Good man
I hereby declare that the secret has not been leaked, I did not tell others.
Otherwise, I will lose faith in people, no one wants to be friends with me.
My mouth is as strong as a zipper
Although sometimes I will chat on Facebook and accidentally say it, I have no intentions.
What is uncomfortable is that all screaming and venting is just my inner drama in reality.
You, do you like to keep secrets for people?
Or like me, to be crushed by these secrets
I am Anna, Anna living in Gotham City.
Thank you for watching today's advertisement.
Don't tell them! ANNA!
Squarespace is a good web design website
No programming required
No ANNA! do not talk!
You can get free membership by entering Squarespace.com/anna
Enter coupon code "anna" for 10% off